good morning thank you for coming I'm
just going to jump right in because
we're on limited time so I'll start by
just telling you a little bit about Who
I am and what the talk is going to be
about what sort of things we're going to
cover my name's Ryan I am by day the
director of decision engineering at
GrubHub my group works on things like
automated dispatch algorithms courier
scheduling simulation sorts of things we
are a sister group to the data science
team as well so my background is in
computer science and operations research
can I get a show of hands of who out
there actually noticed what operations
research is a fair amount okay if you
don't know what it is you're not alone
it is probably the worst named field and
pretty much all the quantitative
disciplines it was formed out of the
world war 2 industrial military
industrial complex when we realized
collectively that we could take human
systems like factories or transportation
networks or grocery stores anything like
that and model them mathematically and
improve them using optimization
mathematical techniques you may have
heard the saying the data science is the
sexiest field of the 21st century
operations research is sort of the
sexiest field of the 1950s
lately there's been some interest from
the data science community in learning
about optimization and operations
research techniques so this talk
seeks to take the grounding that you
have as data scientists and build
optimization understanding around some
of the models that you already
understand and that's that's a good
starting point because under a lot of
the sort of classical inferential
statistical techniques especially things
like regression there there's always an
optimizer somewhere in there so so we
can take something like a least squares
regression we can model it using
scikit-learn we can then deconstructed a
little bit and say this is how we treat
it as an optimization problem and then
from there we can build more general
models that do other things and like
make decisions and the reason for this
is that you want to do this is that the
more general or abstract optimization
techniques go sort of a step beyond some
of the things that you can do with
predictive models in that they they
handle interactions between complex
decisions well so we'll spend a lot of
time on formulation there won't be a
whole lot of math there will be a little
bit I'm not a statistician and I'm not a
mathematician so if you see an error let
me know it'll improve the slides and
maybe I'll buy you a beer but there will
be a lot of different kinds of models
that we show I think I'm going to give
three data science models and a couple
application type models that we build
off of those you can follow along by the
way it with the ipython notebook it's in
my github Ryan J O'Neal under the talks
repo just look for the current date if
you're that sort of person there's a
requirements txt so you should be able
to run everything just make sure you're
using Python 3 because python 3 or go
home
so we'll go a little quickly but the key
takeaways here are that most of the
testicle many of the statistical
information techniques that you're using
already have optimization under the
covers if you want you can take an
optimizer you can model them the same
way maybe it won't perform quite as well
as what you're using in scikit-learn
because it's not specific to that
purpose but it's a great way to
understand how optimization works and
how you can take those same technologies
and do more general models with them so
as with any sort of statistical
inference work we start with least
squares so basic problem statement we
observe some noisy data we want to fit a
curve to it so noisy observations in for
a function we're going to generate some
random data to start with this way we
can we have a ground truth to compare to
so I'm just going to use the function y
equals 3x squared minus 2x plus 10 plus
epsilon where epsilon is a Gaussian
random variable so that's my noise right
there I'm just going to plot a curve and
add noise to every every point on it so
here's a little code to do that you can
see I'm just you know generating random
data here the Y I Section y equals
section is the function that we talked
about and the EPS which we add to it is
just the noise parameter I'm going to
stick these in numpy arrays I apologize
for the code in the ipython notebook I
tell people that I write old man Python
none of the fancy tools like pandas all
right so we plot this you get a nice
curve a little bit of noise in there so
now we have a ground truth and we have
some random data that we've generated
that we would like to fit and see if it
compares favorably with our known ground
truth
so first way we'll do it is with
scikit-learn right so this is pretty
simple all we have to do is import the
regression class and scikit-learn I'm
not going to go into determining what
the features are but assuming we've done
our homework we've looked at this curve
we've said gosh it's got a nice upwards
curvature there's probably a linear
component to it and maybe an offset so I
need to fit it to those three pieces
right so we want a quadratic term a
linear term and an offset so this is
your basic scikit-learn linear
regression model all's I got to do is
import linear regression I'm going to
manually construct my feature matrix and
you can see here I'm explicitly giving
it the one for the offset because I want
it to come back that's I want it to fit
the model that way because I'm going to
do that again later right so I've got my
squares my squared terms my linear terms
and my offset terms so I construct my
feature matrix X manually this way I
just fit that to the observed data and
it gives me back three negative two and
ten approximately which is what I put
into it so that's good
how'd we do well that looks about right
okay so next we're not going to do this
with the other models but with linear
regression or at least squares it's it's
so convenient we might as well if we
didn't have a computer what we would do
is we would think about the function
that we want to minimize right so in
these squares what I want to minimize is
the sum of the squared residuals so why
is my observed on my observations and X
data are going to be my predicted values
so y minus X beta is the residuals right
I square these they all become positive
and I just sum them up and so now what I
have is a function that defines a spate
a function that I would like to minimize
what I want is to find values for beta
that minimized the the value of the
total value of that function right and
you'll notice here that I've just added
a 1/2 to the front of it that's simply
for the convenience of the optimization
it doesn't really matter if I'm
minimizing this function times 1/2 or
times 1 or times 2 you get into
different kinds of optimization for a
regression there's different norms you
can use as well and so one of the things
that's convenient or cool about using an
optimizer to do things like regression
is that it becomes very easy to switch
out different norms a lot of the time we
use least squares regression because
it's really convenient to work with it
because of a nice closed form solution
we get out of this so if I just multiply
my terms through I find inw I so on and
so forth
this is the actual function of my
residuals right this is the sum of the
squared residuals so if I can find a
minimum for this and it's nice and
convex and all that other good stuff
then I have values for beta
so I dig out my calculus book and what
we do is we take the first order
derivative of this function and set it
equal to zero and I know that'll be a
stationary point right and since the
function is nice and convex it'll also
be the global optimum solve it through
and I get this beta equals x transpose X
inverse X transpose Y which is the
pseudo inverse so what if I what are we
done here what we've done is taken a
problem that it's kind of hard to solve
because we've got lots of observations
which which form these equations which
conflict with each other and we have now
reformulated the problem as a
minimization of error so this
restructuring of the problem allows us
now to solve it we'll get a little bit
more on to let that later but basically
we've done there's something taken
something that is unsolvable and
reformed it into something that we
cancel and well we've used optimization
to solve that new thing yes
that has
look for for Ryan J O'Neal and on github
and there should be talks and then under
under 2017 July and you'll have you'll
have to use the requirements tape stand
there if you want to because it requires
some libraries so let's implement this
using numpy directly so this is just
where we're going to do beta equals that
pseudo inverse function and then just
print out the results that we get and
you can see they're the same as what we
get I believe they're exactly the same
that's what we get from scikit-learn let
me check on three point zero one
negative two point one zero yeah so it
gives us the same result yes I didn't
time these they're both so fast you
wouldn't even notice if you were to you
if you were really doing this not just
in a toy problem you wouldn't do an
invis because that's inefficient you'd
probably do some sort of factorization
jealous key dump decomposition or
something like that and I'm sure that's
what scikit-learn is using internally I
actually have no idea but yeah with
these kinds of problems the you can
think of these things as just
technologies they're so fast and they
are they are numerically stable that
generally you're just going to put
information into them it'll just come
back to you with a good solution most
almost all the time all right so how'd
you know Grandma and Grandpa do with
they're talking Slava sits late our
pilots late and numpy same solution so
that's all well I'm good but we've gone
from feeding this data into scikit-learn
and having it do all heavy lifting for
us now to thinking of it with an
analytical or closed form solution let's
do it a different way so let's say you
have this crazy uncle Eddie that used to
do optimization back at NASA or
something like that when he thinks about
least-squares what he thinks about is is
there a more general technique that i
can solve problems with this like like
like this with like this one and he
knows that in the cbx off package
there's a kewpie method for quadratic
programming
ignore the term programming they can
solve anything of this form right so it
can minimize anything where P I believe
it's positive semi-definite and it's
more general than the form we just used
to solve these squares right so if you
ignore this the subject to the
constraints at the bottom this top
function this minimization looks pretty
familiar right ie it looks a lot like
like this if we just rearrange the terms
and we drop out that 1/2 Y transpose Y
which is a constant so it doesn't even
matter
right so if we're going to solve it with
this all we have to do is reframe our
objective function and fit in into this
model and our solver will do it do the
heavy lifting for us right so how do we
do that so we have to convert from this
form here I've ranged rearrange the
terms and all we have to do is say P
equals x transpose X and Q equals
negative Y transpose X and now I can I
can stick it right into that solver
we'll just do it for me ok so this is
the third way of solving least squares
and again the one-half Y transpose Y is
a constant so we just drop it P I
believe has to be if you look at the CVX
opt docks you'll I think it says that s
to be positive semi-definite but that's
going to be the case with X transpose X
anyway so that's fine so here is the CVX
opt version using QP I have to do a
little bit of a lunging to get the data
into the right format but as you can see
it gives me back basically the same
solution that these squares did and you
should expect I think generally with
this it will be fast not quite as fast
as your second learning Li square solver
because this is using I think under the
covers probably an interior point method
or something like that it is using a
different solution technique which is
more general and solves classes of
problems so here's the output of uncle
ideas version of least squares so we can
the same so we've now just solved
least-squares three totally different
ways we've solved it using so I could
learn sort of an out-of-the-box approach
we've solved it using a closed form
method the hard way and we've now solved
it using an optimization solver they can
solve anything that's quadratically a
quadratic program so any problem that
meets these criteria it can solve so why
would we go with this third technique
what does it give us the real advantage
here is that in indecision modeling what
we try to do is create algorithms that
solve general classes of problems and
then when we need to solve a problem we
identify what class it belongs to and we
model it using that right so we the
problems themselves are somewhat
separated from the algorithm to solve
and so there's the activity of algorithm
development and optimization and there's
the activity of model formulation and
that allows us to think about things
very separately but it also allows us to
apply very specialized tools to large
classes of problems so if you think
about well I want I want to use least
squares to solve a problem but I want to
make a small modification to it how
would you do that right if it's not
something that's supported by
scikit-learn or a similar tool that
becomes very difficult but if you've
modeled it using something like a
quadratic optimization solver well now I
can do I can throw in different kinds of
regularization I can make it epsilon
insensitive so that you know if I know
I've got a certain kind of measurement
error that I'm dealing with I can just
ignore it
or a lot of other things that my
optimization solver will allow me to do
because it solves a more general kind of
model
all right so let's go through an
application this is going to take that
same quadratic optimization solver and
it's going to do portfolio optimization
with it so it's going to use the same
exact code that we use to solve least
squares in the third instance and it's
going to now optimize a portfolio all
right so the basic idea with portfolio
optimization is we have a bunch of money
we want to put it in two different
investments and those investments have
expected returns and they have
covariance matrices on their on their on
their returns and so we want to maximize
our returns such that we minimize the
risk that we're subject all right and so
our inputs to this model are the amount
of money that we have and the different
investments we can put it in of course
we can't make negative investments in
this model and our risk tolerance which
is sort of this unitless measure we're
going to take a hundred months of
exchange rate data from the Fed I just
have this sitting around from 2014 so
we'll use that because it's convenient
if you want the link in the slide in the
ipython notebook actually will link to
correct with the CSV so you can solve
this yourself although I haven't updated
the data this particular data set in a
few years right so this is what our
optimization model looks like mu is the
vector of expected investment returns
just based on historical data so of
course we're making the assumption that
the past will look or the future will
look like the past I guess the past
would also look like the future in that
case we'll compute a covariance matrix
this will help us minimize our risk and
alpha is our unitless unitless measure
of risk aversion and what we're going to
do is we're going to fiddle with alpha
and we're going to generate a Pareto
front which allows us to to make
trade-offs between risk and return so
the model itself is pretty simple we're
going to maximize our return minus alpha
times our risk right so mu X that's our
expected return alpha X Sigma X that is
the measure of portfolio risk
that looks similar to the model we just
solve this least squares and then we're
going to do the sum of all our
investments has to be one right so
they're non-negative I can't make a
negative investment and if I invest
point one in some particular currency
that means I'm investing 10% of my
assets in that currency so they have to
sum to one all right
well this is a maximization problem and
we just solved the minimization so how
do we do that we just multiply by
negative one and now it's a minimization
problem so this is our model all right
covered this so we're doing obviously a
convex combination of the investments
all right so we pulled into everything
into panja's I like when I said as a
muse panda's computer covariance matrix
and now we feed it into CB X oft
repeating it into the same function this
is still the QP function we have a lot
more arguments to it because we have
those constraints on it now essentially
we have the constraints that the
investments are non-negative and that
the sum of the investments has to equal
1 so we're investing our entire
portfolio but it's the same function and
now what we're going to do is we're
going to run this against lots of
different values for alpha and you'll
get a lot of awful looking output and
you'll get a curve looking like this so
what we've done here is taken a very
very generic method for solving
quadratic optimization problems and
we've applied it to two completely
different things in one model our
decisions were what are the values for
beta how do we fit this curve are the
decisions that we're making in the
second model the decisions that we're
making are how much of my investment
portfolio do I put in this particular
asset same optimization procedure all
right let's go to a different model
support vector machines so we have two
sets of points and we want to draw a
separating hyperplane between them again
we're just going to generate a bunch of
random data and put a line through it to
the to the extent that we can so we have
these epsilon parameters that are some
toys right so here's some code generates
random data for me and what we're going
to do is represent these points such
that we're trying to separate the Blues
from the oranges and of course we can't
quite do that because they overlap in
the region's but we can draw a line that
minimizes the error that will be our
support vector machine
so if we do this with scikit-learn again
fairly simple we just import the SVM
library and we run fit on it I'm using
the linear kernel here because the use
of different kernels are sort of beyond
the scope of this talk but we could use
different ones and what we're looking
for here I use the decisions that we
want to make are what are the values
that give us this separating hyperplane
that minimizes a classification error so
this is the this is the output of
scikit-learn SVM library and doing that
and the way the classification works is
if the value of the observed of the
observation in that function in that
line is greater than equal to zero then
it's a one type and if it's less than
zero the other time right so this is our
confusion matrix so the the correct
predictions are on the diagonal and the
incorrect ones or are the other points
this is just some code boilerplate code
to get a nice visualization of this
going in bouquet and this is what it
looks like what I've done here is remove
the orange and blue and the correct ones
are light gray whereas the incorrect
predictions are these red squares right
so this is this is our this is our
baseline now all right so let's try this
using an optimization solver so we're
going to use a library called pulp here
pulp is a modeling tool that lets us
solve anything that's linear and it can
also let us do some mixed integer
optimization so what we're going to do
is reframe our psyche our support vector
machine model such that pulp can solve
it right so we're going to minimize
these errors subject to a linear set of
equations
so how do we do this well we first
construct a vectors of the inputs for
our observations where X I is the point
of the observation where is it on that
graph and Y is plus one or negative one
depending on what kind of thing it is
and then we build a model out of that
where we have these epsilon variables or
Syberia Buhl's sorry that are the actual
errors right so if a thing is
misclassified then we penalize and these
two inequalities here force a
penalisation onto the linear solver
whenever is something is misclassified
you can see with a little bit of
algebraic manipulation those just work
down to one one inequality which is kind
of nice so this is the model this is
this is linear support vector machines
this is this is one of the models you
think mr. solving so we run this through
pulp oh wait
yeah if you think back a few slides the
linear optimization solver solve things
that are of the form ax equals B these
are of course ax is greater than equal
to B so we just have to add an extra
variable transformations like that are
fairly standard in linear optimization
so this is just getting it into the
right form federal in your optimizer can
understand
all right so let's create a pulp model
so these are decision variables B W 1
and W 2 we also create variables for our
errors though those aren't exactly
decision variables these are variables
that we are going to optimize against so
we're going to relate the error
variables to the decision variables and
penalize based on the errors so this is
that nasty-looking constraint that we
saw earlier we just add it for every
observation and we set an objective
function being the sum of those errors
and we solve it I'm going to create a
predict function of course normally you
just do this with scikit-learn directly
but since we're building everything
ourselves
this just determines whether it's a plus
1 or a minus 1 and we get the same
confusion matrix so that's all well and
good so now we've just built our own
support vector machine
I'm going to skip by the problem shapes
because we're running a long time but
it's kind of interesting to think about
if you go through the slides okay third
model that we'll cover is clustering so
let's say we have a set of unclassified
data and we want to figure out how to
how to how to cluster together around
centroids all right we'll generate some
data just like before
so again random data with noise on it so
these are our Centers I'm just going to
choose them a priori we're going to have
three clusters alright so this is what
it looks like
all right we'll do this with
scikit-learn so again I import k-means
here I fit it it's nice and fast does a
good job and gives me these as my
centers which are roughly right ish
close enough and I'm going to build a
plotting function that just shows them
by color and shows me where the
centroids where the model decides
centroids are so gray here are the model
centroids or cluster centroids and
they're done grouped by color let's do
this with linear optimization in this
one we're going to have to add variables
binary variables to determine which
centroid which cluster a particular
observation goes with and we'll have
linear variables that penalize its
deviation from its assigned centroid all
right so we have a new set of variables
Y which are 0 and 1 and it's actually
makes solving our models it can make
them a lot harder and this one it will
and it's just simply because it's not
continuous so you have to employ
different methods but I'm still using
the same optimization solver or
optimization library to solve it
all right so our inputs locations of the
observed points and we have to make two
kinds of decisions here one decision is
where are the center's where do I put my
centroids and the second decision is
which cluster is each observed point
assigned to since it's a linear
optimizer I'm not going to be using
euclidean distance we're instead using
l1 norms here so this is a
representation of that and this is what
the model looks like
so primary decision variables locations
with the cluster centers secondary
decision variables which cluster do I
associate each point with and we were
required that each point be associated
with exactly one cluster fairly simple
this just guide the optimization using
the l1 norms or the taxicab distance and
we're not going to talk about symmetry
elimination and then we set our
objective as the sum of the distances so
again we're optimizing over something
that is related to the decisions that
we're making running it actually takes a
while for this model there are better
models for clustering and integer
programming I'm not going to talk about
those here and so again we create our
own predict method and get out a similar
result let's put the cluster centers in
a different place I'm assuming that's
just because we're using the taxicab
distances but hey we just built our own
clustering system that's kind of cool
so the problem here is that if you run
this model it will probably take a
minute or so to solve even a very small
set of data right there are much better
ways of doing this in inter programming
they're way beyond the scope of this
talk but I'd like to show something it
is a little more realistic with the
minutes that we have left so our second
application is going to be pedicab
sharing I created the slides before all
hell broke loose so you know your
brother and your grandmother and your
parents have all started
ride-sharing companies so you decide
that it's your turn so what we're going
to do is generate some pedicab locations
and we're going to say that each pedicab
can have up to two people at a time and
then we've got a bunch of people that
we've got to pick up and drop off right
so this is essentially what's called the
dial-a-ride problem if you look in the
literature alright so this is just a
function to build out where the pedicabs
are and plot them and what we see is
this is just random data again but the
green squares are the pedicab locations
blue triangles or pickups and they're
drop-offs have dotted lines to them so
this is this is the demand that we have
on our system right now so our questions
really are what are the routes that we
give these pedicabs
and you know what pedicab picks up and
drops off which customer so we'll use a
technique called column generation all
of these examples by the way are just
sort of textbooks so there's references
at the end you can find them all in
there I'm just I did the service of
translating it all into Python for you
so column generation is we're going to
generate a bunch of routes and we're
going to use an optimization to
determine which of those routes to use
so we're going to generate a lot of
routes a lot more reps than we actually
need and then the question is which is
the set of routes that will serve all
our customers at the minimum cost
and then we're going to subject it to a
model that is a partitioning model on
one side and sort of a packing on the
other
I II we're going to service every
customer and every pedicab can have no
more than one route so we've got these
Perdition or we're going to cover and
pack basically at the same time
depending on how you think of that
alright so what we're going to do is run
a little code that generates a bunch of
different routes for our pedi cabs all
of all the feasible ones and score them
by by distance that's what this code
does and we have at the end of that
process 2387 possible routes to choose
from we have a binary variable with int
with each route assignment deciding
whether or not to use it and each
customer gets serviced by somebody and
no pedicab has more than one route I
just add constraints for that
now our objective is to minimize the
total distance and we'll just we'll
think of that as a proxy for cost to us
in reality we probably have something
very different and our total cost ends
up being 814 so we plot our solutions
and that's what it looks like
and then the pedicabs come back to us
and they say well I have to travel too
far right so now we're going to do is
willing to add a secondary objective
which minimizes the tool make it
minimizes the maximum trip length right
and so that makes our costs go way up
but they're called their route links go
way down well that's not very good for
us right so now what we do is solve
another optimization problem which says
well give the pedicabs that our routes
or shorter routes but only hurt our
margins by 10% right so now we can see
that we're closer to our original cost
our best cost and our routes are not as
long and we get this sort of a solution
out of that so this is a more realistic
example solves very quickly so I have
some links in the Python notebook as two
good books that you can look at if
you're interested in this kind of stuff
I also have to quit a quick quick
shameless plug for GrubHub we're looking
for data scientists data people if
you're interesting that kind of stuff
our mission is to use math to feed the
hungry so you can email me or find me
here thank you Ron great session
now we'll take a few quick questions
thank you maybe it's just because I'm
just City Jupiter cannot open your
notebook it says it's not jasa so what
should I do
I will make sure that it is working
yeah so the good question was what's
wrong with the notebook and I'm not sure
at the moment
videos it may be are you sure you're
running using Python 3 and the
appropriate version of Jupiter I will
make sure that it is working email me if
it doesn't we have a working one all
right any other questions
sorry you definitely covered this but
can you go back to talking about some of
the the benefits of these more flexible
models over just using the libraries
because part of it felt like a lot more
work for the same results right yeah I
would I would say that if you're here if
your plans are to do statistical
inference you're probably not going to
use these the the purpose here was just
you use it as a launching pad for
getting into more general-purpose
decision modeling so if you're if your
interests are what you know what what
what capital budgeting decisions do I
need to make how do I need to route my
my drivers how do I need to invest my
money that's those sorts of questions
then then these are the kinds of tools
that you'd want to use but for
statistical inference I probably
wouldn't be oftentimes with like things
like the scikit-learn libraries they are
they are well adapted to those kinds of
problems and they are their custom and
much faster and of course the question
was why would you use this as opposed to
something like a scikit-learn
last question
so in machine learning we use 20 descend
very calmly so what do you think about
the use of the gradient descent method
in operation optimization I'm sorry I
have to confess a little bit of
ignorance I'm assuming you're talking
about things like extra boost the
question is what about using gradient
descent in optimization so when if
you're doing something like convex
optimization and you're just using the
gradient you're going to get a fairly
poor optimizer but that doesn't mean
that the that such methods aren't
applicable in most optimization
libraries we like to have second order
information because that gives us
curvature but it may not always be
available so those methods are also
useful and I think I mean I don't know
much about that the applications of
those in machine learning but my
impression is that there's tended to
work very well with machine learning
libraries so I wouldn't discourage it
but if you can get second order
information on a model it's always good
to do so that that's all time we have
Thank You Ryan great presentation
[Applause]